hey here's some sort of funny news but
it still does tell us a little bit about
just the major issues that Donald Trump
is going to have as president of the
United States the background of Trump is
he's the guy with the friends who are
stars the elitist the Hollywood types
etc and it's kind of true but only to
some degree it turns out that Donald
Trump is having so much trouble getting
popular American artists to perform at
his inauguration that he's had to bring
on a British singer to perform and even
she is making demands to Trump for her
participation you really can't write
this stuff now before I tell you about
Rebecca Ferguson I want to remind you
that Elton John Justin Timberlake Bruno
Mars Katy Perry Garth Brooks Andrea
Bocelli kiss Celine Dion David Foster
and Kanye West all have either turned
down offers to perform or said that they
would turn down offers if asked because
they were their names were being floated
to perform at Trump's inauguration so
who is coming in it's British singer
Rebecca Ferguson she is known for being
the runner-up on a past season of the
British version of the x-factor reality
show I know that that's hard to follow
Rachel because it's it's it's quite a
few layers removed from who you would
think Trump would have as at the top of
his list she's been invited to perform
at Donald Trump's inauguration but she
has demands she is saying I'm only gonna
do it if I can perform the song strange
fruit which is a song from the 1930s or
rather protesting 1930s racism in
America written by Abel Meeropol Trump's
transition team has not yet returned a
request for comment this is the American
presidential inauguration and Donald
Trump is bringing in foreign singers not
that I care personally I really don't
but if you're all about America wouldn't
you bring in American musicians maybe
there's just none left I mean this
reminds me of during the campaign when
he would play music at his rallies yeah
and then those bands that he was using
their music from would come out one
after another saying we don't even like
you why are you using our stuff I mean
that includes the Rolling Stones Adele
Neil Young Steven Tyler REM they were
all against
they all were and you know what why just
not get Ted Nugent it seems that Ted
Nugent is the reliable performer for
Republican stuff the inaugural committee
has announced three acts so far we will
be treated to performances Rachel by the
Radio City Rockettes the Mormon
Tabernacle Choir they do some big-time
stuff and sixteen-year-old America's Got
Talent star Jackie Evancho so I are you
looking forward to these performances he
said throughout his whole campaign that
he didn't need the whole celebrity
Fiasco went right jay-z and Beyonce and
all of these other celebrities were
supporting Hillary Clinton he claimed
that he didn't need that yeah he could
get by on his own and now we're seeing
that seems like he's gonna have to yeah
Trump as Rachel points out has been
acting like he doesn't want so-called a
listers he tweeted I forget the date on
this let's see if we can see it this was
in December 22nd of December he tweeted
the so called a list celebrities are all
wanting tickets to the inauguration but
look what they did for Hillary nothing I
want the people well that's gonna be the
story you'll have to tell Donald when
everybody other than a British singer
who was the runner up on a past season
of British X Factor's the the the only
star willing to accept your invitation
now to be very clear Rebecca Ferguson is
a great singer I say that with peace and
love
I hadn't heard of her but I looked her
up and she sings really really well but
is this what the American president has
to do now go to foreign singers
something about this makes me a little
sad Pat if it weren't for the fact that
Trump is a narcissistic megalomaniac I
might actually feel bad that nobody
wants to play in his sandbox I'm kind of
surprised that Kanye West wasn't willing
to perform because he said that had he
voted he wouldn't know it it for Trump
yeah that's where of course Rachel loved
that because she's a big big Kanye West
fan we found out yeah I just think that
all of these celebrities who claim that
they did not want to perform for him
probably just don't want to alienate
their fan bases yet it's it is you're
okay you're making the point that it's
possible I'm thinking of when you say
that some of these celebrities might
have also not performed at Hillary
Clinton's inauguration merely to stay
away from politics that is something
that you sometimes
with with singers who say it's not good
business for me to get involved in
politics do you care about the politics
of the musicians that you listen to well
that's a tricky question now because of
what I said about Kanye West forget
about kind of a free I would say in
general yes I don't
I can appreciate their beliefs if I
disagree with them but I don't want to
be paying money or supporting someone
who I think supports policies that are
completely different than mine and I may
perceive as harmful I agree I agree I
don't you know I've learned over time
about some musicians that have beliefs
that I fundamentally disagree with and I
can say I'll ignore that and just listen
to the music but I'm aware of it and it
impacts me I don't know about you I
think that's the easiest to do with
sports because there's this clear
difference of what's going on the field
Rises off the field yeah but with
something like music I mean that's your
poetry that's your whole outlook on life
so that's right that definitely would
have impact me yeah but so many singers
don't even write their own lyrics yeah
but they're still making a decision as
to what songs they're going to perform
right they're buying they're buying the
lyric from someone do find it really
difficult to believe that he could not
find one musician from the u.s. to
perform at the inauguration well maybe
it's just not musicians that he wants
right like the people he wants are all
saying no of course there's a million
country singers who would show up at the
drop of a hat they pay to show up and
perform at Trump's inauguration but
maybe it's not that the vibe that Trump
wants and by the way Trump has had to
sort of pretend like he likes country
music during his campaign does anybody
believe that the rich Manhattanite loves
country music it's very hard for me to
believe that I'm not buying it I'm
surprised they didn't just invite the
Mormon Tabernacle Choir to just to do
two sets instead yeah or just do covers
do covers of the songs that would have
been done although probably those
artists would say copyright now you
can't do that alright let's take a break
make sure to give us a like on Facebook
facebook.com slash david pakman show
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated